et dans les vosges ce soir 80 mille
foyers attendent toujours le retour du
courant
c'est le cas à la bresse dans la station
de ski il a fallu organiser la vie des
cinq mille habitants et des 5000
touristes présents sur place pierre et
cali ce matin à la bresse quelques
groupes électrogènes supplémentaires ont
été installés comme dans cette maison de
retraite
déjà fait l'essentiel
sailly renom maison progrès et
charlie l'essentiel dans la ville les
bresso patiente même si le quotidien est
transformé le 28 mai nantes en attaque
manque d'âme je ne sais pas ça m'est
arrivé à houston
et pourtant la bresse possède sa propre
régie d'électricité mais bien un
suffisante à elle seule pour subvenir
aux besoins de la commune
quant aux touristes ils restent
philosophes et des dieux pour se laver
s'habiller pour les bagages briller sur
les pistes de ski c'est un peu le
désarroi évidemment aucune machinerie ne
fonctionne
seuls les amateurs de luge peuvent
encore s'amuser